games done quick has become a regular
celebration of speedrunners and the
amazing feast they're able to pull off
in video games
and best of all this is all tied to a
charity event meaning every donation
goes to a good cause with that and agdq
2022 wrapping up let me take you down a
list of highlights from both this year
and past events
our first highlight takes us back to
agdq 2014
this was the year that sinister one
pulled out a blindfold and showed the
world that punch-out could be
legitimately tackled by sound alone
while it wasn't his first time
attempting this he certainly showed the
world what was possible here are just a
few highlights from the event
[Applause]
all right so this next guy uh when i'm
doing
single segment runs is called the
gatekeeper
because he's really really difficult to
guess get past he's one of the most
random fighters in the game
and uh that's not too good when you're
trying to fight him blindfolded so
he's he's the gatekeeper and blindfolded
as well
while sinister one would eventually get
taken down by mike tyson he made it
further than ever deemed possible by
sound alone and punch out at the time
mike tyson was thought to be virtually
impossible blindfolded inspired by this
run d-tysonator would eventually prove
this possible
continuing with the blindfolds in 2021
bubzia proved that he could not only
beat super mario 64 in 39 minutes and 9
seconds
but he could beat a 3d platform game
completely blindfolded utilizing only
sound and music cues the mastery of
mario 64 on display here is astounding
with bubsia performing complex
platforming while blindfolded while
using punches walls and camera tricks to
stay on course we're not going to use
the cannon to get this star that is
inside a wall we're going to
fall alongside the wall and somehow
magically
grab it out of the wall but it's a very
precise setup
and um
yeah for precise setups you need precise
inputs
and
punches for example like here to
move forward the exact amount of
uh
well
distance
really helps to set this up finding
ledges like here
uh punch again some camera manipulation
this is a very complex one to
actually
explain every input of he got it first
try that's awesome
people like to call it that jumping um
below this platform oh no we can
actually see here
um maybe
i can't hear the game right now but you
should be able to hear a shuffle sound
because like how do you how do you know
you're at a wall how do you know you're
in a corner those two
actually have a different sound cue so a
wall
is kind of like
you can't get close to the bottom do
this
let's do this
using the whoosh sound
to time this throw
i think it's a two frame window earlier
wow
time by the way
geez
pretty good run i think
but how do you take blindfolded and keep
raising the bar to preposterous levels
well this year's agdq 2022 had amitris
show us how to play seikido blindfolded
and beat it in just over two hours just
for a little background information as
the game loads up here uh there are
three people in the world that have done
this i believe mitch is of course the
first and
in my opinion you know the legendary
blindfold runner for it um and then i
have also done it one time i took five
hours to do it but i did do it one time
to slam into that into that and then
he's gonna do
a thrust and then he should do kind of
like a rage attack which is like five
deflects in a row that'll perfectly line
him up
all right lining him up in the corner
right here just has to get a little more
on the posture
throwing down those firecrackers getting
the stuns in between even throwing in a
little bit of pocket sand and that looks
like it's gonna be a perfect setup
unbelievable i can't believe we just
watched that one more health bar to go
another yashiriku sugar
and we see okay there's a second md he
probably needs two more for finishing
this off
it looks to be a pretty good position it
depends which way easton dodges here he
might get stuck on that wall
oh he squeezes he's gonna do it that is
it
the no damage amazing work by mitch here
a flawless final boss fight first try
that's super super super impressive
unbelievable
another aspect that has become standard
over the years for gdq is
races while it's fun to watch a great
speed run sometimes it can be even more
exciting to watch a head-to-head
speedrun competition in 2014 we saw a
four-way race in super metroid which
exemplified just how intense and fun
these races could be the contestants
four of the best super metroid players
in the world were neck and neck just
about the entire race and near the end
one of the furthest behind players
krauser managed an incredible maneuver
on the top right screen to catch up
[Applause]
these are for the top players in the
world and their personal best times are
separated by 45 seconds or less which is
insane because this run is about 45
minutes long
so this has got it
garrison right after this
do you notice because they got grabbed
they have to go back and get their
health back that's something krauser
might not have to do if he gets this
oh he's got one section in the way
he's up and over
ivan gets the shine spark up the climb
zoe's right behind him
this is down to fundamentals at this
point yes it is ledge grabbing
he's got it
i've been up the parlor gets steamed
he's gotta watch out
looks like as long as he does not get
hit by steam he should have this he gets
it's hit but so does zozo gets hit as
well
this most recent game's done quick agdq
2022 saw some incredible speed runs in
its own right the first i'm going to
point out is this hades race for races
we actually make a few modifications to
the game in order to even out some of
the rng to allow the player's skill to
really shine through yeah and some of
you may be noticing that these runners
are making their decisions incredibly
quickly so quickly in fact that you're
not going to be able to keep up and read
what they're selecting
at this point these these runners
they're skilled enough they can sight
read everything they basically they'll
just snap pick things before you even
recognize they're on a screen
tony's actually picked up
epic rush delivery right before the end
of this so
wow he has so much damage right now
that's 455 doom crocs oh man
it is absolutely melting away seagull's
not far behind here just entering the
hades fight now
36 000
out of 90 000 you're all incredible
that's that's amazing that's so good
we can probably space those out a little
bit right
now we need to do
it has been fascinating watching the
evolution of dark souls speedruns ever
since way back in 2011. these
speedrunners make a challenging game
seem simple and pull off incredible
techniques and skips that require the
utmost mastery so it was a blast when
this year's agdq 2022 decided to include
an all boss's race of dark souls
featuring dan flesch and regal
three two one go
okay
perfect like this
we're good sources line up between their
different weapons and how early you can
upgrade
so that was the last point they're both
going to be synced up for a while yep so
regal is going to level up some
dexterity and dan is going to go and
kill this black knight in the hopes of
getting the great sword
hollow was not very gentle i got the
legit sword oh he got the actual sword
nice oh my god it's like
that's like a one 26.7
yeah 26.7 chance should be a real sword
i'm gonna talk about dan cause he's
going in to do um sensegate skill
while regal is going to fight gargoyles
yeah i'm trying to get to another
dangerous room
yeah
because of the difference in weapons it
makes it faster for regal to do this
early
um
while dan is gonna use when he comes
back to fight gargoyles to upgrade but
to get the upgrade materials
for his weapon and do some other menuing
all right so yeah dan has triggered a
death cam plane
in this area there's a death campaign
and an actual kill plane
and by doing that parry you push
yourself sort of slightly out of bounds
and you can trigger the depth cam plane
and not the kill plane
that gives you this weird looking top
down camera but because you move our
camera down for some reason like dogs
behave differently and they never make
it in time
and you can hundred percent safe
punishment so you're going to learn that
he talks about the
camera manipulation just casually
falling through the world
yeah so what he's done here is a
transition clip there's an area
transition from lower undead work to the
depths and by quitting out he manages to
i think if you store your position
in lower undead bug but the map is the
depth or one way around or the other and
you just fall through
um
the map that isn't loaded because your
positions aren't really on the other map
um and this lets him skip
running through the depths and you can
just jump over the fog gates straight
into the fight with the gaping dragon
going into the dlc from that bonfire is
a lot faster there we go they're not
running from any other bonfire yeah this
roof is real weird
like hard to get up there we go
in weird places
i'm gonna do a clip in bounds up here
ahead as well
it's like the same mechanic should be
two perry's here hopefully he doesn't
oh that was ice messed it up
same thing
all right
and time will be whenever the cutscene
starts
i didn't even realize people were
speedrunning stardew valley but i
learned that bombs are far more useful
for farming than i ever realized this
was definitely one of the more
unexpected speedruns out of azdq 2022
but surprisingly entertaining and filled
with some absolutely incredible glitches
basically what it does is allow a note
name to be open up his inventory in the
middle of a cut scene delete tools to
make space for a whole bunch of items
that have just spawned in his inventory
yeah you know it's a good start to a
farming simulator when the absolute
first thing he does is get rid of his
farming tools
so our opening moves are uh we're gonna
open we're gonna we're gonna blow up our
front yard the way we got all those
items at the beginning is because uh the
way dialogue works in this game
um or the way you get items during
dialogue in this game is there's
basically a hidden id code um somewhere
in that dialog
and then when you do that dialogue the
person will give the item to you when
they get to that point in the dialogue
because what is happening right now is
we are filling out multiple bundles
before any of the other bundles have
spawned and the game doesn't know how to
handle that so it's going to trigger all
of the bundle bundle spawning cut scenes
at the same exact time and when it
spawns them it will simply continue to
spawn them um and what i mean by that is
every time you layer one of these cut
scenes uh it would play the other cut
scene again
for as many times as you triggered them
there
personally i am a fan of kaizo mario
it's the way i tend to make my mario
maker levels and it's the type of mario
maker levels i tend to play for those
unaware kaizo mario is a term that has
come to represent insanely difficult
mods of super mario i simultaneously
love and hate playing these but
especially love watching people suffer
as they try to tackle this absolute
brutality and in the most recent agdq
2022 kez cage showed off the most
difficult kaizo mod ever showcased
before the gbq casio mario world and
pulled off some absolutely insane
maneuvers
just a reminder this this is this is by
far the most difficult kaizo mod that
has been showcased at gdq so there's
there's going to be a lot of deaths
[Music]
that's why we're going to die
more times than anyone else in the
history of gdq and uh i hope you're
ready because we're cozy you know at six
in the morning we're chilling get coffee
so we need this bullet
actually for the rest of this level
uh we need to make sure this bullet does
not die so we're gonna do a little like
shimmy shake you know we're doing a jive
we're we're having fun that muncher
staircase i'm easy so unethical
uh so this is a baby skit it lets you
skip half of this section it's insanely
precise
it's really really difficult it's
extremely precise
um and speaking of precise ooh do you
like precise bumpy jumps because i don't
but too bad because we're doing one here
at the very end of this level check this
out this last jump is is really rough
in the first place this is one of the
hardest jumps in the game
bumpy hitboxes are just terrible first
easy is the easiest game in gdq also one
two three
[Music]
this is very stressful too he has to do
this long ride all the way up through
these boot rings uh while controlling
this bubble
uh so what's really difficult about this
is you're bouncing very quickly and you
have to re-grab the jump button to get
little hops
uh and if you re-grab too early you can
hop way too early if you re-grab too
late you hop too late and either one of
those things is very easy to do
and then
this is time coming up
it's hard enough to become a master at a
game and pull off an impressive speed
run on your own
but with it takes two its bites and who
is hyper had a master speed running the
game together and they had an amazing
run at agdq 2022 filled with impressive
exploits and funny moments so you're
gonna notice right off the bat they're
gonna go into a slide here and these
slides are really important for us
because it's the best way to gain speed
in this game and we can get into slides
through a couple of ways we can we can
slide out of sprints we can split out of
dashes we can slide out of frog jumps
and we use we use all of those in
different applications to like get speed
they have different like lengths that
they can go but we mostly use the sprint
slide jump as you're going to see them
use a ton uh over here on this side
because basically the slide jump gives
us extra height it gives us extra
distance and we use that to basically go
on top of surfaces that they don't
expect you to get by grabbing onto the
rails on the other side and just get
right to the end of the level and kind
of ignore a whole donkey kong country
freaking mine cart section of the game
where you go
all the way around and now this is the
deeply rooted wall climb more fast
action here as they use the light
fixtures to get out of bounds here and
start climbing up the nooks and crannies
in the roots to get up out of bounds
climbing up this extra branch here they
can see the daylight and now they're
going to slide jump there to carry a lot
of momentum and try and dodge a death
barrier oh my god barely playing like a
man possessed right now
the hyper is going to try and come in as
low as he can here there's going to be
some grass that shows up at the bottom
of the tunnel and as soon as he crosses
it he's going to start pulling up and
heading towards the top right we can see
the daylight
oh my goodness that was not as planned
so we're actually going to intentionally
lose a little bit of time here
just to show off
that you can
fly around in the guts in here
so this is just really funny
while resident evil village only just
released early 2021 the speed running
community has already latched onto it
and seven ray d showed us at this recent
agdq 2022 just how impressive their
skill level is by doing a run on not
just hardcore mode but the more
challenging village of shadows mode this
mode is meant as a new game plus mode
but he performs it with zero of the ng
plus benefits
and glitch-less and now hopefully
everything goes alright
can be a bit random how this dude
behaves
yeah by standing on the staircase he can
avoid the grabs you see he's he's trying
to grab but he just can't quite hit ray
uh so it's a nice little strategy it
only works on the stairs
i guess we didn't even talk about it but
these borders are weak to cold air and
we basically just in the first fight we
broke a window
let cold air in here we have to open the
strap door on the ceiling we'll let the
cold air in
and there you can only damage
when
they're
i guess in a cold
oh i don't know
after paying attention i didn't get a
shotgun shell dropped during the
castle at all so
that would be considered a little bit
bad luck makes this fight just a bit
slower
yeah luckily with the rng in this game
um on like drops and boxes none of that
can none of it can really be like run
ending can't think of a better time to
donate 50
resident evil check
rhythm music game unlock check kingdom
hearts prizes check a sega prize pack
with multiple games
double check good luck on the run
so in this room where basically we need
to break these lights which will stop
this fan so we can climb
at the top out of here but there are
these like
oh
okay that blast worked um yeah there are
these new jetpack enemies introduced
the jetpack soul that's basically very
similar to
other enemies here
but yeah we just flashbang and run by
like dark souls bloodborne is not only
an absolutely incredible game by from
software but also a load of fun to watch
speedruns of at agdq 2018 jesus hears
toast gave us a fantastic and incredibly
entertaining all boss's speedrun of the
game we've come to a blood minister and
he's cured us and we wake up here at
yosefka's clinic
with the urge to run
and we could hear some sounds coming out
the door
what is it
a wolf
eating a corpse so we're quickly going
to run away
i'm going to run past all these guys we
have no business with them quite frankly
i'm a pacifist i'm out for my morning
run and i have no reason to kill
anything now this is sewer skip
we jumped on the ledge rotate ourselves
line up jump plunge right onto the fence
that's probably the hardest skip in the
game
and we just nailed it nice let's go
let's go
i'm gonna die at gdq i'm gonna die at
gdq and it's all your fault gascoigne
no i'm not i lied parry visceral get out
of here you try to meme me you try to
meme me
who do you think you're talking to
in 2014 tazbot or a tool assisted
speedrun bot was used for the nintendo
ds game brain age and
here are the results
now you might notice uh he just blew on
it i don't know if that's going to help
this works it works trust me
all right here we go this is the intro
to figure out how old you are
so eight minus eight anybody know the
answer
zero okay two times nine
[Applause]
hey it's the right answer
ah that works
[Applause]
uh
well this is a japanese game so
[Music]
wait
did you expect that
[Music]
oh okay no it's restarting it's
restarting okay it's restarting we're
gonna be good i think we're good we're
gonna be fine
[Music]
oh this this doesn't bode well
i have a donation here from taskbot it's
325 dollars and says from taskbot here's
my money
if you're not actively watching speed
runs of a game there's something special
about seeing one of your favorite games
on the lineup for gdq and witnessing
just how far this be running community
has come as well as what exploits and
skips they found to save precious
seconds for me that game was hollow
knight at agdq 2019 visuals showed the
world an impressive number of techniques
the community had discovered such as
dying and utilizing your own shade for
major skips team cherry creators of
hollow knight even hopped on and donated
ten thousand dollars
and so here's the first fireball skip um
basically
we use a fireball to keep our uh our
height
and kind of push us a little bit farther
left than we normally would be able to
make jumps that we kind of can't
see if we can pull this off
easy nice
[Applause]
there we go there's some triples
so that's basically the fight um
he's gonna
stop
unless that dash into him
magnet is the hardest attack to dodge
oh my god
get away from me
we're fine we're fine we're fine
everyone calm down
we have a 10 000 donation from team
cherry
oh my goodness
thank you guys
teamcherry251 says hey everyone really
excited to be a part of hdq hope it's
another great one big thanks to visuals
for running into the couch team for the
emotional support good luck with path of
pain and again let's go for the couch as
well you all are doing a great job so
far thank you thank you
of course while games done quick is
known for all the incredible speed runs
on display the best aspect is that it's
a charity event and this was the moment
when summer games done quick managed to
raise a whopping 3 million dollars and
fittingly right during the epilogue to
chrono trigger
and there you have some of our favorite
highlights from this year's agdq as well
as from the past games done quick is
filled with an incredible amount of
amazing moments so let us know what some
of your favorites were and we'll see you
next time
you